you're gonna nah you're gonna not
because that's beyond your wildest
imagination that's the reason why it's
so grateful that's the word gratefully
of the word grateful is the word to get
which one's this baby 939 you sure
hmm yes it is sng 39 let me do the intro
today okay sometimes I like it it's not
like when you do it sometimes I like to
do it no do what every day that you do
it I can't be bothered to do it not like
you ever know that I can't be bothered
I know but no trust me I know because
you staying just like another
sounds like it but every day that you do
it I can't be bothered to do it but once
you started doing it I want to do any
one you want so now I'm gonna jump the
gun I want to do it to that girlfriend I
want to introduce myself so my name is
James I'm from Memphis Tennessee I'm out
joking and so this is SMG that would you
say 39 sng 39 guys it's been a long trip
so far thank you so much for being here
and make sure you follow us everywhere
you can be so if you're watching us on
YouTube like subscribe comment
you guys stay busy in the comments and
we try our best to reply especially on
the social so Instagram Twitter hit us
up on there if you want to support us
further become one of the patrons we've
got some good folks on there message us
get exclusive content get early content
whatever you want get discounts on the
merch speaking of the merch link is in
the description jump on sng fam show us
what you're wearing and I think that's
in it I think so Gang Gang Gang done
right unless you haven't even urgent to
say nothing urgent just sure thing gigs
in it hit me with a [ __ ] gig would
you rather mmm let's say you can do all
three and you have to choose but you can
only choose one for the rest of your
life yeah you can do all three things
I'm about to say yeah we have to choose
one
all right yeah would you rather be a
famous ridiculous the best actor in the
world the best musician in the world mmm
or the best actor musician was the third
one [ __ ] actor musician and comedian I
knew you were gonna say comedian Oh
which one would you be my heart tells me
mmm comedian mm-hmm but my dick tells me
musician
my dick is screaming musician explain
explain why your heart tells you
comedian my heart tells me comedian
because they're people that I look up
most to in the world and that resonate
with me are comedians
typically mm-hmm so and I obviously the
whole the whole premise of this show is
to make people laugh yeah and to and
mainly to make us laugh because I don't
know what I don't know what's gonna make
people laugh I know what make me young
and I know will make you love where I
hope something I say will make you laugh
so does the premise of the show's
laughter yeah so it would make sense
that if I could elevate my game to the
highest degree he would be in the
laughing dynamic yeah however musicians
get [ __ ] musicians encapsulate sex
mm-hmm like we know think about people
like [ __ ] Prince yeah and Lenny
Kravitz and [ __ ] anyone bravia Marvin
Gaye Drake [ __ ] anyone Tory Lanez
they just Chris Brown dick encapsulate
sex this is all about the [ __ ]
yeah and they get nothing but they get
nothing but for see yeah and this is
it's crazy and it's like a the way a
great musician if the world's best
musician can manipulate emotions not in
a negative way yeah but can create and
atmos any atmosphere they want to create
they can create whether it's happy funny
sad sexual
anything they're in control of it yeah
by the sounds that they can create mmm
either with their voice or an instrument
and that is phenomenal
yeah so my dick tells me is screaming
same musician I want to wear open top
I wonder our blouse yeah I won't wind in
my head I don't know it all of that and
I wanted for China
hmm but I think I'll have to see what my
pants a comedian if I could be the
world's best comedian yeah and just
because I think commune is a
storytellers yeah their story - I would
give anything to be the world's best
storyteller yeah anything what about you
I'm gonna say comedian as well but not
for the reasons you said it I'm gonna
tell you the reasons why I won't be an
actor or a musician okay cool
so I won't be a musician at the balls
best I don't want to I don't want to be
the world's best musician because
regardless of whatever music you bring
out it is always gonna be there's always
gonna be it's always gonna be a genre
where some someone doesn't like your
genre yes you know I mean yeah yeah yeah
you can't you can never please Everett
there might be a song someone might like
but you can never please everyone with a
genre true so that's the mainly and when
you're talking about sex and like [ __ ]
and stuff all three all three categories
get [ __ ] oh of course they do don't get
me wrong I know I know but when it comes
to musicians [ __ ] it's yes thrown in
your face every day and it's harder to
even if you do get it it's harder to
keep it quiet yeah so that's why I
wouldn't do that okay because my life
would no longer be my life mmm it's
gonna be very lives I'm gonna be living
my life for them yeah acting I think
it'll be it'll be amazing but I'll be so
long because I will never if I'm if I'm
the world's best actor I'm assuming I'm
booked and busy Oh 100 so I'm never
gonna have the time to be just me
because I'm always acting mmm yummy
mmm so I say comedy because laughter is
laughter you guys regardless of what you
say someone's gonna laugh do you
throughout your whole sketch or whatever
you do you gotta laugh at so at a joke
at least yeah at least
at least you're gonna laugh yeah
tsunamis it doesn't matter your skin
tone whatever it doesn't matter what you
do comedy is always gonna make you laugh
yeah 100 that's the reason why I choose
comedy not necessarily because I feel
like the other two are better or worse
but I feel like with comedy you've got a
better chance of grasping a higher
audience in my opinion or a vaster
audience hmm you know more a bit more
diverse whereas music it's only a
population of people that listen to a
certain type of music hey with axing or
let's say for example Leonardo copy or
Dez I watch them they can act different
roles granted that's good ii do
different types of movies but within his
aim breath i'm always act in a party
over myself
yeah the times i am myself i just want
to [ __ ] chill as well like if you're
what you feel the world's best actor
you're basically the world's best
pretender presenter you're the world's
best person at not being you hmm and
that's not something I would wear so
that's the relax the reason why I choose
comedy over the other two you play
that's a good shot man I hear you man
and yeah the laughter thing is universal
man people find making people laugh is
the best single best thing you can say
it's a great feeling
single best thing you can do like when
people I have so much respect I think
I've said I've said I probably said a
lot so I have so much respect for people
who can make people laugh mm-hmm and I
have respect for anyone who manages to
make me laugh
and I'm not saying I'm hard to meet love
I love for all kinds of [ __ ] but I like
when people like we like we have a
common friend
for example mm-hm and they don't always
make me laugh mm-hmm
they try to not to make me specifically
laugh but they try to be funny a lot of
the time okay and sometimes it hits
sometimes it [ __ ] hits and I I
literally want to give them a round of
applause I think you doing well
I can tell you who I'm talking about but
I don't feel like you will understand I
don't feel like you'll understand okay
but I'm talking about okay and off
camera I tell you where but when they
hit mmm I'm like I want to stand up and
clap golden golden yeah
bro this time you [ __ ] slapped it
yeah like well done okay
and I just that just fills me with joy
mm and if anyone in any random scenario
they're hit quick or they just they're
like super quick weird or they come back
or they're just naturally funny like
some people aren't trying to be funny
yeah and they're just been serious like
you're one of those people like you are
funny when you try to be but also you're
one of the funniest people I have ever
met who's trying not to be funny the
funniest one Front's people I've ever
met who's not trying to be funny just
your your shoe reactions to things kill
me it's just your nonchalant laissez
blasé and just don't take [ __ ] at you
like look take don't take [ __ ] more
about the I don't want to be in this
situation and I'm not I'm not shy
everyone in this room not knowing that I
don't want to be here yeah but I'm not
gonna say anything
yeah cuz I'm polite yeah but all you man
no I don't want to be here so don't even
talk to me I know what you mean it's
[ __ ] unbearably funny I don't know
what you mean um
and like you have a way of how do I say
it when you're done with something
you're so done that it makes me cry like
we could debate you debate and go back
and forth for Michael for from back and
forth and at the end of it whether you
think you're right or wrong
yeah you'll just be there black I'm just
like no we're not finished aren't
Sharman and then you just move on like
you literally not even emotionally
invested in the conversation you'll move
on fam like you're done when you're done
you're done you're not just telling me
you're done you're actually physically
done you're not even here anymore you've
moved on and it's so funny
ah I wouldn't keep working for like so
many people who watch this podcast to
meet you one day and I just heart just
makes me laugh it just makes guitar
appreciate that that's funny but what I
was gonna say when I said hedonistic got
any for urgent mm-hmm and that was a
nice one that he gave my back's all
[ __ ] up it's all levels of [ __ ] you
and me both mum I need a massage
um proof recently there as a story that
came out
which would resonate with us really well
ok zin this is in this sector and it is
the perfect on Pillai said however many
episodes it was ago that money makes
people crazy yeah and you've got to be a
stern character to turn down money yeah
perfect example of money making people
crazy doing making people do crazy [ __ ]
and [ __ ] up their life because of it
so context basically there's a podcast
it's an American podcast for two girls
yeah it's called cooler daddy and
familiar he's famous he's only been
around for like a year or two business
sounds being yeah I think I've seen on
Twitter mmm it's big and it's it's
basically the girl version of us okay so
all they do is talk about [ __ ] yeah
um to be fair that's harsh I don't want
to guess what they do but the main
premise of the show is that sex related
right okay and their experiences with
sex and stuff like that so basically
there's a situation that's come out with
their podcast with offices to to girls
they're Britain's they started off with
nothing mm-hmm
and basically they got taken on by its
company called bar stool okay which is
the best way to describe it it's just
like a how do I describe it imagine kind
of it's just a platform basically so
it's like YouTube or Spotify or whatever
there's just a platform it has podcasts
on that platform you can also find them
on all the other platforms but it's
supported mainly by that platform right
yeah so they're sponsored by barstool
but they got picked up by barstool
unlike episode two or three early early
and I was annoyed because just to take a
quick sidestep I was annoyed because I
thought wow like not that they're so
good that they got picked up that early
but how lucky how lucky are you to get
picked up plucked at Episode two and
then your life your career just show up
like people are thinking wow lightning
does strike and I will be guest if that
happened to us obviously didn't but I
guess ever happened to us Arbogast if we
make that our own way whatever but
that's cool that that's a possibility
yeah it's at least you can say like it's
an it's never gonna happen or is
yeah happens to people when stuff like
that and bro that's been in my head
since I ever heard about that which was
like a year and a half ago and then I
found out as of late it turns out that
one of the hosts actually knew the guy
who runs the barstool anyway and then I
was like wow so you didn't really get to
like that know where it was set on that
new something friend even knew a friend
too yeah I was a bit like oh it's not
the same it's not the same it's not the
same gratification yeah not like this
not at all I was just like oh that [ __ ]
but never mind mmm like it's kind of
like it's more a bit like us imagine
like us going on like Joe Rogan or
something and I'm good ass yeah I'm gay
no we're gonna Joe Rogan like and I'm
not oh my god like this sick like the
biggest [ __ ] in the world we're gonna
go on there because of the like content
that we put out and then we find out
that like Bella just knows actually know
someone who works with him as a favor
loud newspaper ringing one table oh I
see the gas to do here but it's not this
is not the same is it it's not growing
back same and but anyone back to the
main story they got picked up in like
Episode two
yeah and in the space of like a year and
a bit they they shot up yeah it did one
of the biggest podcast in the world they
shot up so basically they signed an
initial three-year contract to get paid
like 75 grand a year
in dollars mm so what's that like 60 60
50 something grand and bearing in mind
they will [ __ ] they will have nothing
before yeah one of them didn't even have
a job so they're nothing so that's
pretty good
yeah that's pretty good in the scheme of
things in terms of obviously they didn't
know what was gonna happen in here so
they didn't know they wouldn't take off
there so burning my where they were is a
good deal into what they are now is
awful deal but um so they had that deal
but they have bonuses and stuff so by
the end of the bonuses they'd load way
more money yeah because it taken off so
much yeah anyway we get to the end of
year 1 and they want to start going into
negotiations into re contracting so they
want to get paid more obviously and one
of the girls
has like who doesn't do there's a Mingo
who does most of their editing and stuff
I'd has another one who pretty much just
shows up I don't even think she does
much chroma or anything but anyway
they're going into the negotiations they
want more money than one more money kind
of thing and initially the main geezer
who runs bar stool was like nap but now
again nothing yeah and they were like
cool so the girl who doesn't do as much
her man worked for like HBO something is
one of the execs for HBO who says all
you need to be making way more so he
drafted up this is actually no this is
what happened before the official
negotiations he drafted up like a demand
there but this is what we want yeah so
he drafted up is that you're not getting
what's even liked industry standard
considering the size of the podcast so
you deserve this this this and this and
this I've trusted all together you can
send it off to my man a barstool and see
what he says
obviously my man a barstool came back I
said [ __ ] off okay asically
yeah to the light cool so it all dies
down or dies down and then they say
right go into official negotiations bar
stalled on is like right I want you to
comp both of you to come and see me at
my apartment and we'll suss it out and
we'll get something together so they go
to the apartment
they're expecting oh you can have this
but you're not having this you can have
this to be not having this so they get
there and apparently my man is generous
cause and says right here's a new deal
yeah you get 500k each a year you stay
on for the following two years and at
the end of the two years you get to keep
the IP which is intellectual property
which means that when they leave bar
stall they still get to keep the name
call her daddy they still get to keep
the merch and all that stuff they get to
take the podcast with them over they go
because if they break contract at the
minute and they don't have their
intellectual property they can't start
another podcast call color daddy Barthel
owns the cool air daddy okay so you have
to start on meeting find a new audience
oh [ __ ]
so it's a big deal yeah I he's a big
deal so basically he said right here's
the deal
at the minute they're on 75 grand they
don't have the IP at the end of their
contract there's a three year contract
and he doesn't have to increase it over
75 grand if he doesn't want to they got
a bonus scheme but doesn't have to do
anything so he after year one is as cool
yet five hundred grand each and then at
the end of the contract you can have the
IP and some other [ __ ] as well so the
main girl who does the editing and stuff
for that was like gang she didn't say it
but she was like gang gang gang gang
gang never was gonna happen yeah this is
perfect yeah they leave padding the
other ones up no now I'm happy I'm not
happy she wants more to us more she
wants more
so basically it goes on for weeks now so
bad that they're going back and forth
that they're not even making episodes
anymore
the whole thing is on hold while they're
sorting out these negotiations to accept
this deal or not to accept it and the
one things like I wonder except don't
wanna accept I want except the other
things like not enough it's not enough
it's not enough when yesterday if I'm
you know 75 grand now you weren't half a
million yeah and it's still not enough
who are you though and the thing is as
well obviously she's saying I wanted
someone there something like this I want
this bearing in mind the only reason
they're in a position that they are in
is because Barthel took them on in the
first place and they were fuchal yeah
it's like us episode 2 a bra nothing
nothing yeah so to even get a 75 grand
was a thing now to offer you 500 million
in one year five hundred five hundred K
in one year is everything and you get to
keep your show at the end of the
contract yeah so you can just do this
whenever so apparently she came back and
was like no I wanna of like I've got a
few more demands kind of thing I come
early they sell alcohol under their name
and they have merged and all that stuff
suit she said I want this percentage of
the alcohol with this percent other much
on top of the 500k I want but this
percentage of this this percentage of
this and apparently they even came back
and were like fine you can have this
fine you can have that fine you can have
that and at the end she was still like
actually now I want more what the [ __ ]
and to the point where she was mugging
it so much that their main ting
had to say to the barstool Donny I'm
really sorry but I just want to let you
know me and her and on the same page
like I would have accepted it when we're
at your yard and I don't know what she's
doing but I'm worried we're gonna get to
a point where you tell both of us to
just [ __ ] off yeah so aren't you late
you know now I want to start negotiating
my own deal because she's checking the
whole thing and she's taking a piss and
I don't know when she's gonna say yes
bro fast forward a couple weeks call her
daddy now house with one girl on it that
one's gone no I was gone greed man greed
breaks people I don't know what she
wanted but greed breaks people but now
obviously the main things gone behind
everybody's back to secure her own deal
their friendships dawn yeah done but
they were just but they were both
obviously there were girls in it they
were boys just like me and you they were
bred RINs and this whole ting in the
space of a year so this is basically me
and you next year
yeah the whole thing is [ __ ] our whole
relationship is [ __ ] all because of
money money greed not even money greed
because they were getting like half a
mil fam tell me where to sign cuz if you
offered me 75 today sign and even in a
year's time you said like you need to be
making my ward will negotiate five-year
cuz I make you more than I was for what
this I'm happy I'm content greed [ __ ]
man I uh the funny thing is I saw what
when you said call me daddy because I
saw it on a set of Sauron Switzer and I
karma he showed it to me maybe maybe
Bela showed it to me I was looking
through their YouTube page I was
thinking obviously they started last
year maybe you're in half ago but I saw
a few gaps so they weren't hitting
weekly I hit weakly yeah and then they
clocks that they didn't record from like
let's say one month till maybe like two
months later mmm that's why I realized
Bobby I didn't realize I went from two
girls to one because I don't really pay
attention that much I'm just looking at
a time frame and seeing how consistent
they were obviously consistencies
clearly is key bro so
100 I saw that and I was like that's the
prime example about money making people
crazy why would you let that happen
while especially if you were like boys
or girls beforehand bro how could you
let that happen
I would I would shake you shake what you
do it's a man I wonder why I deserve
definitely imagine if imagine like
imagine if that was the the wall that
you were hitting like if I was shaking
you now found what do you want what do
you want yeah and we were making nothing
before yeah then we start making 75
grand and now I'm making half a mil what
is it that you actually want you and you
decide I want why I deserve that's not
answer I don't know but you want my
deserves I don't know money bro greed is
a is a different thing
mm a different thing is especially if
like well obviously we'll take this for
example us for example obviously D like
the edited and stuff and if I was the
one demanding for [ __ ] like does she not
have a conscience kind of do you know I
mean yeah yeah I know what you mean she
she knows she does [ __ ] all or she does
about 30% if that hmm can you really be
in a position to be asking for more bro
like what's what's gone to your head to
make you think like you deserve more
than $500,000 a year I don't even know
what that is a month it's a lot or after
tax that's probably I'm gonna find out
now actually 500 is what it must be like
15 grand a month more that's disgraceful
of our money more more more probably
more this is such a waste of time
no no thing ran a week I was thinking
I'm just intrigued cuz 500 grand off the
tax is how much you make well this is in
pounds anyway 23 grand a month 23 a
month grand a month 23k a month 23 grand
a month would be what's the name cos I
mean I can't remember name is it Sigma
does 6 just under 6
Rand a week chillin chillin post tax she
looks grand what am I doing with that
what am I even doing there's not too
much money
let me see you deserve more for what to
chap will be contributed to chat to to
stories to talk about dick now cuz
that's greed cuz I'll suck dick for that
I'm sorry I'm good you sir would you and
the thing is and the other episode about
sucking dick
we were talking numbers numbers yeah
billion six grand a week post tax said
of us in your life
Gluck Gluck yuk yuk the rest of my I'm
chilling firm Oh grazie my god are you
crazy
broad that's bonkers that is bonkers
just over a grand a day I didn't even
think about that you couldn't give me a
thousand pound a day a grand a day just
over five K week 23 a month and then
after tax you take home 276 a year
obviously tax is heavy in UK so you go
it's more than 50% I think it's more
than 50% when you're hitting if you know
hit in that bracket I know it's just
it's 45 percent I was gonna say surely
not more than what you made 45 percent
when you're hearing that kind of brand
day that's one thing though I am happy
in the UK what obviously business owners
is different but employees obviously in
the UK get their their tax immediately
deducted out their paycheck of course so
they never see that money and more time
I didn't even check my paycheck so I
didn't even know what it would have been
in the first place and I know I always I
don't I don't want to know but it's
actually obviously I know in America
they're so you have to pay their taxes
so they have to take the money that's in
their bank drapes it out and just give
it to the tax man that's too painful
that's why that's why they all go jail
if I'm making that kind of money I would
popping Joe 100% Jesus Wow I don't know
what was that a hiccup that my tongue
was in a way I don't know
bro that's that's dirty dirty that's too
much green mom it is if we ever reach a
point of 500k we've made it we've made
that 75k I feel like I've made it as
soon as I can quit my job
oh yeah to be fair rogues I've bet as
soon as I can quit my job I've made it
as soon as I don't have to do this job
I've made it because then you are now
living your life was it you're living
your life for a living yeah 100% yeah
that day bro these man that listened to
Kenny he's gonna listen don't get a
party I'm gonna party when that day hits
I'm gonna party I know you I will slap
friends and colleagues in the face of
joy I found old scream I was scream I'll
be so [ __ ] there that's all I want in
the world
fam every this is so gay everyday when I
hit 11:11 make a wish that's why I wish
for every single day if I see a level 11
I make a wish that's exactly the wish I
make it's not gonna come true now
because I've just boy I've just told
what the wishes but bro it's so
important to me
it's so important to me I know it's
crazy I can hate working [ __ ] the
thing is look you know we was talking
last time about what like Co videos
taught you and talking about career
paths and stuff like that it's
definitely taught me this podcast has
taught me that I actually don't hate
working I thought I hated working but I
spent hours and hours doing this this is
work he takes hours of my time yeah you
just hate your current job but I don't
hate a single second of it
there's nothing about it I hate
obviously there's times where we're I'm
up at like [ __ ] took look in the
morning yeah waiting for [ __ ] to upload
and I'm gonna start off yeah but the
actual process of the work
I don't hate a single second of it it's
just working for working in a place
where you don't see the point in what
you're doing yeah you know I mean yeah
it's just like especially when it's like
a cycle its cycle
this mad but I forgot to say that we had
a fan request a few weeks ago and it's
been sitting in my phone waiting was to
be addressed a feral cat I think request
ok topic requests from fan a few weeks
ago yeah and it said hang on let me find
it la-dee-da while he's trying to find
up as you can see I'm not wearing a hat
today James did a little I did I cut his
hair let me know what you think in the
comments below but it was hard gee I
feel I feel I feel lighter
I felt like my head shape is a
difference like different sides
completely it's weird it's so weird so
weird but yeah I feel like I can embrace
life again still go away for the barbers
though but thank you my nerdy anytime
right cool so I'm not gonna out them in
case they didn't want me to yeah but
where's the message hey I love your
podcast I watch it every week and I
think would be the funniest thing if you
talked about what you would do if a god
if a girl got her period on your sheets
girlfriend and not if I'm [ __ ] her
and she's on a Red's already knew she
was on the Reds anyway do you know I
mean it's not like she would have she
would have told me it's not a surprise
to anyone yeah yeah if I'm still willing
to [ __ ] her I don't really give a [ __ ]
about the sheets
yeah Haley cuz I don't give a [ __ ] about
my bed clearly so the sheets are the
last of my worries yeah yeah yeah I'm a
grown-ass man I'll [ __ ] you if I want
dude I mean do you bang on period of
course I do to go please say that would
never like I rate you for saying there
were chance but you need to understand
every guy has done it every gut no
matter what you say every guy has done
it every guy has done it and I'm not
saying I would [ __ ] every single go on a
period no yeah yeah yeah like girls I am
actively seeing yeah you dude like
Rhaego but it depends on it depends
we've had this conversation I'm I'm
intrigued you have to be fairly number
but yeah
it doesn't change okay I'll tell your
story the first time I had encountered
like any sexual things happen in waltz
the girl was at a period was by accident
I didn't go down on or anything
obviously thank God
yeah but we were messing about mess this
was back in uni we were messing about
and then I think I was fingering or
something real it's in lips her lips in
and she's told me to stop for a bit then
I think she went to them to the toilet
obviously she kind of maybe she felt
like maybe she's yeah yeah I mean it she
went to the toilet and then she told me
she was on her Ed's I was like I'll [ __ ]
is a good thing that we didn't do
anything so that was my first experience
it's not like I don't really freak out I
was just like rah okay they st. gonna
happen kind of thing so maybe just and
then I think after that the first time I
probably [ __ ] a girl I was on her
period was probably only a few years ago
mmm yeah but from that time to the first
time that explained the story was years
in between do you know me
so it's not like it's something I do
like actively but I feel like every guy
has done it I never ever whichever like
not every guy like if you're older like
you're like a man if you like my agents
all your age and I mean you're doing it
fun you're doing it so girlfriend or not
go if someone I'm seeing oh it's my
girlfriend mmm if she's on a period I'm
a ball horny big man I'm [ __ ] it
because if I don't give a [ __ ] about my
dick going in there I don't give a [ __ ]
about I clearly don't give a [ __ ] about
yeah she [ __ ] the sheets I don't care
about in that [ __ ] I'm more laughing
I'm more happy to put like a towel down
and then [ __ ] up the towel you know I
mean cuz at least were taking some sort
of precaution dude I mean cuz I'm not
obviously not wearing a condom you're my
missus so this was like no one's gonna
die nope like let's be real nothing bad
is actually gonna happen
mm-hm no matter what you do she's not
gonna get pregnant cause it's on a
period yes it's blood it's a bit gross
it is but you don't have to go down
there you don't have to look at it can I
mean there's so much pass the pic is so
true though it's so true and I think
people will be so surprised at how open
I am oh I'm so well I'm surprised I know
people are gonna be so surprised but I
feel like
the people that are either a in
relationships would understand or be
have they've had it happen before today
I'm in a place and when I oh that's
probably reason I did it because they
just don't give a [ __ ] hmm and I think
the more you realize that not
necessarily that's it scenario but the
more your own [ __ ] the more you don't
really give a [ __ ] about what people say
yeah say yeah that's my take on it what
about you I agree with what you said in
terms of everyone's done it yeah I
groove what you said in terms what
everyone's done it and sorry Mona
[Music]
everyone has an exact unnie yeah I
definitely do not do it but I've done it
and when I did it I was young mmm I was
young and she's not learning I haven't
done this since I was a teenager okay
and I was horny nods and the first time
I did it you know we were talking before
about the cold sweat of shame after you
know that he just like the first time I
did it ended up being the look like the
worst way it could have gone down you
know I mean because it was one of those
ones where you laying there horny lips
in dry sex everything and I'm like [ __ ]
you know I'm mourning I can't even
confirm this anymore and I remember
specifically bless her heart she can
give head sever life yeah so and I'm not
nothing
yeah like this is not gonna happen and
Mike my blood is red hot or so I'll go
back to that yeah
she didn't give head to save a life yeah
so I was just like oh this is unbearable
at this point yeah yeah so and shoot and
then she said the whole like oh well
like um this is kind of my last day I'm
basically coming off kind of thing and
I'm just like all right and then we kind
of got into going to it it was dark
didn't look down there didn't go down
there nothing yeah banged not knotted
yeah
and then afterwards I was a okay that
wasn't so bad
turned the light on my fam massive
chainsaw chainsaw and it was the sheets
were [ __ ] up it was on my wall somehow
and I was just like hmm I'm gonna say I
was thinking I'm gonna be [ __ ] sick
but I didn't want her to feel bad in the
air I'm just like shaking shaking cuz
I'm not horny at all right now I'm the
least funny I could possibly you're
scared I'm gonna burn this blood
everywhere
I'm shaking and shaking and I'm
immediately thinking I don't ever want
to do that again yeah because it was
good at the time yeah but now it's not
worth they're not yeah um but in the
moment everything's worth tonight
everything in that moment everything's
worth them maybe circle back to Mike to
what I said coming south what you said
about how she was coming off so that's
the type those are the times I have done
it when she's let's say is for example
with seven days of period last seven
days unlike day one two seven one two
four oh one two five
it's gonna be [ __ ] heavy mm-hmm so I
usually do it they like six or day seven
yeah slowly about to go I don't do it
like peak and the thing is I say I do it
it's not it's not something I've done in
years properly or like a year in a bit
I mean but I can't sit here and say one
I've never done it and two I'll never do
it again cuz I know I will do it again
mm-hmm I know I'm gonna do it again soon
I mean yeah so fair play G and I'm just
gonna say I will go back to that sucking
dick point when I've linked to go up
before this is time ago as well where
she came over and
[Music]
that is it going over the last one II it
is that's that should be fine did you
save life shed that I've already saved
the last one okay we just didn't delete
it off but I didn't delete off cuz I
have to delete it I didn't yeah I just
didn't delete off okay that's fine oh
yeah cuz it was separate that would use
two separate ones yeah I just didn't
delete it off yeah hang on no cuz if I
stop it's just gonna do it again isn't
it ya know Morris I'm also saying
[ __ ] was I saying
heron hi I'm Roberto
I was linking I was linking a girl quite
a while ago now and she was on a period
when she came over she only not that it
has anything wrong with coming ever
why's he on a period but she told me
while she was here not before she was
there again it wouldn't made a
difference because I probably was that I
asked her to come anyway even if she was
even you've told me prior and we were
messing about like lips in or whatever
dry-humping and all that [ __ ] like you
said before and she wanted to get me
head mmm the thing with me yeah everyone
everyone know what she just knows me and
and how I like her yeah yeah if if it's
not like sloppy top like your hands are
messy your throat is messy don't bother
yeah I mean yeah yeah also even if it's
not that my mind already knows I'm not
gonna [ __ ] you because you're in your
Reds
dad this is no and I'm not circling back
to the [ __ ] on a red stick I would
never [ __ ] a chick that's on a Reds for
the first time it would be like like I
said I have to be seeing her so and this
was one of the first times I was linking
this girl and she was on her Red's so I
wasn't I was not gonna follow up I'm
gonna follow carry on you know I mean
yeah yeah yeah so my brain already knows
I'm not nothing
so all this thing is pointless all this
head is pointless fam I can't not know
in full world up all I'm gonna do is sit
here and you suck my dick when I know
for a fact the head you're giving me
isn't gonna make me not so then that
that makes me go a bit limp yeah and
then she feels like oh maybe I'm not
good enough for oh did you like it's
like yeah but I'm just not gonna know
because I know yeah I need to knock
through pounding that's how I'm gonna
and if my brain already knows I'm not
[ __ ] its this is all sort of facade
is pointless it's worthless
I was gonna say there's been times where
I've actually had to physically just
stop a go mm from giving me a head
because I know she's on her Reds and I
know I'm not gonna come I know I'm not
gonna come from a head because I we've
had we've done this dance yeah we've
done this done yeah I can't come from
your head I'm I'm sorry you're just not
good enough yeah and that might not even
be her fault maybe she's a clean sucker
and I'm not like you I need everything
drenched if I don't if that's you be
fair I don't need it ranged that's my
favorite yeah but if you if you're a
hard worker and you know that deckers so
kind of like like with headers were like
the only way I'm not there's two two two
prong method to making me come from head
either a ghastly mess yeah a ghastly
mess a ghastly mess and it's essentially
a skull [ __ ] yeah yeah or technical
precision yeah so you know when
obviously going down on a girl yeah and
we've spoke about before like when
you're in the stroke yeah and she's on
the way up if your cheek moves seven
degrees to the right she can't come yes
mantra motion yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
like me so if you like you need to be a
technical superstar and we need to get
the stroke and the timing and everything
perfect if you're not a sloppy mess yeah
you need to just it just needs to be
rhythm rhythm consistency speed I know
and perfection know what you mean and
she didn't have ain't either of those so
I literally got to the bottom are so
[ __ ] horny to honor its I'm not gonna
[ __ ] you yeah and I just had to did you
say stop stop stop stop stop I know what
I was angry but I grew her but I was
just angry the whole situation situation
is that there's a baby you need to just
stop because no offense I'm not gonna
come and if I can't come I can't [ __ ]
you yeah I'm just gonna get more and
more angry I'm just gonna be sad like
a mother's life to everything girls give
me a head I'm just sat there not sad I'm
lying down just well you know what you
just have to like try and force yourself
to get but not like to get harder to try
and force yourself to come yeah to make
them feel like they've done their a good
job a good job they've come here and
done a good deed do you know I mean and
I feel bad and I'm forced like I want I
can't I honestly can't remember the last
time I came from her really honestly
really and I think that's purely because
actually I do remember it was back in
college
it wasn't like yeah at 13 also Wow yeah
bro you [ __ ] serious mother's life
mother's life you haven't come from head
since you were a teenager yeah
but I you know do you know why I think
that is I am so like I love it I am so
the sex I'm having now hmm or like in my
common stage of my life now is different
from the sex I was having when I was
getting ahead when I was coming from
head back then yeah so there's levels
now yeah yeah yeah
so my dick already knows that I can come
from this great stuff now so obviously
oh she don't mean anything anymore
I agree no I mean to be fair when I was
a teenager if anyone was even even
agreed to suck my dick you're gonna not
you're gonna not because that's beyond
your wildest imagination
that's the reason why it's so grateful
that's the word grateful if the word
grateful is the word to get a check the
suck your dick back then
raaah mad you might as well rob a bank
man might as well rubberband mad [ __ ]
but nowadays it's [ __ ] wanna suck
dick cuz they wanna suck dick that's
amazing
so yeah you they have to they have to be
here for it now he for the guess won't
say it's hard for me too it's hard for
me to not from it because I've
experienced different types no cure my
life is so different
yeah this is what my dick is accustomed
you know I mean everyone know what I
mean you don't know but yeah man [ __ ]
you know let's do a mile that's that's
hilarious
Oh God
[Music]
am I the [ __ ] for telling my
girlfriend that she had no right to be
mean to my parents I think I remember
what this one means so my girlfriend is
now our friends house because of this
and I just want to know if I'm in the
wrong here she moved in with me so she
moved in me so my parents have an
outdated way of thinking they're a
little homophobic but they are not that
hard to handle my girlfriend let's call
her Sarah is bi and he has more girl
relationships she's had more girl issues
of the boys ones ever since my parents
found out they have been giving
backhanded compliments or just simply
ignore when the topic ever comes to her
first why why did the pair's even need
to know by anyway Sarah does not know
this and I can't read brother I need
glasses I'm sure of it so does not know
this as she has only met them once face
to face and I didn't really talk to them
much and I don't really talk to them
much so I was calling my parents to say
I want to talk to them I told her that
she shouldn't and she said that she has
not really talked to them
so she wants to be able to bond with
them what cute
I want her saying that my family was
very outdated and she shrugged I didn't
want to hurt her face so a video called
them they immediately realized she was
there as by commenting on her appearance
saying that lady shouldn't wear those
type of clothes around other men talking
about my father who was also in the call
and say I was wearing a tank top and
loose pants Sarah didn't really mind and
tried to start a conversation then my
mother made a comment about our
sexuality saying that it's a phase
attention-grabbing
and I noticed Sarah was getting
irritated so then gave a half-assed
answer and rolled her eyes about five
times during it my mother commented on
that too so I told my mother to shut up
and stop being a homophobic [ __ ]
I was shocked and also mad no [ __ ]
because I was in our favor before that
firm I was so unserious I just before
that comment I'd be like [ __ ] you man
brav as soon as she said that was like
rah bro
Sara half got up and left and my mother
started talking other [ __ ] about her
saying I'm wasting my life and I told
her I had to go and then Emilia told
Sarah that she shouldn't have said that
to my family
yeah satisfied young that my family are
horrible people that she's not
apologizing for saying the truth I told
her I told her I warned her and that she
needs to apologize because they're my
family and if we're going to be dating
we need to respect them and that she had
no right to say that stuff it turned
into a fight she said that she isn't
respecting if they don't respect her I
told her I know they aren't the best but
it's going to be so much drama she
doesn't apologize she said that she
doesn't care and it's good that her
because they deserve it a lot of
screaming so I figure I was all right
cool so basically I'm are the [ __ ]
for so she shouldn't been mean to my
parents um there's layers to this there
are layers but I feel like I'm trying to
put myself in Sarah's shoes in the heat
of the moment of that video call 100 so
prior to this video call her and her man
are rich David everyone knows she's
bisexual mmm everyone knows that why do
they know that though because she's
never even spoken to them before he said
basically they met her once so he's the
one who's told of them that for a reason
for what reason I don't know I don't
know but anyway um he should have I
don't feel like she's she's she's in the
[Music]
she's wrong for singing it but she why
she said it is justified yeah 100 100
cuz it's it's annoying to be to be
charged upon by your own beliefs like
she she didn't choose to be bisexual yes
she just happens to be bisexual yeah
like it's not
doesn't change me as a person if I'm
bisexual that doesn't mean I'm any less
or any better of a person I'm just me no
I mean yeah for the parents to judge her
just off that characteristic I can
understand the frustration because she's
probably been through that with her own
parents right oh she's like I'm not
dealing in this [ __ ] again [ __ ] your
parents hmm that's the reason why I can
I can understand her anger and her
frustration from that initial outburst
because it happens it does sometimes con
control your anger
yeah rags and I think like also that
she's she's trying to gap the like and
bridge the gap yeah like she's the one
who initiated the call once and I want
to get to know your parents yeah like
this relationship is important to me
I've never spoken to them I want to
speak to them yeah and all she gets in
return is grief about her sexuality in
which she's not even the one who told
them in the first place violation the
man told them and also she's dealing
with a backlash about sexuality and my
girls calling her an attention-seeker
the mum the month corner an
attention-seeker asian so it's in my
opinion she's not cheating on us she's
not an [ __ ] for what how she feels
and she's not an [ __ ] for for for
being angry and react him but swearing
to your man's mum is it's a tough time
you don't need you don't need to call a
[ __ ] I know place it sometimes call
control frustrate hundreds in you can't
come time a con and I don't think that
would have happened if she had she's
must have been through this before
oh yeah yeah she doesn't just come it
builds yeah build so 100% and he's a bit
of an [ __ ] for Turner to apologize
like you need to if he's he's an awesome
no no no I tell you what he is an
[ __ ] for not immediately stepping in
and being like mum what the [ __ ] he did
what's gone on it he should from the
first comment yet from the first comment
he should have been like month we did
like or just like
mom do mind they can't believe it like
he just sat there and let his mum jock
it to his girl and then she said
something and now she has to apologize
he's not saying the mom has to apologize
he's basically saying they're outdated
this is my family and if we're gonna
date you're gonna have to respect my
family when your mom was categorically
trucking it to your girl and you said
nothing and did nothing now even when
you're gonna left you didn't even have a
one-to-one with your mum and say what
the [ __ ] you just said told your mom I
have to go like you're still thinking
this calm for your mum to check to your
girl like that and that your girl should
respect your mum your monitors called
your girl and their tension seeker
because of her sexuality in which she's
not throwing it in anyone's face you
told your mum and all of us and she's
one of the attention seeker brother I
would I would that that's a relationship
bender for me yeah right that's a
relationship bender funny like if I was
if I was her and I'm a bisexual and then
I'm dealing with [ __ ] from my girl's mum
who knows nothing about me and I'm the
one that's tried to introduce myself to
her and paint a good picture for her
yeah and she knows [ __ ] all about me and
all of a sudden I'm just attacked out of
nowhere and then my girl doesn't defend
me and even after the call when no one's
around you still ain't defending me
you're saying that I should be calling
people to make amends
I'm not gonna fresh of that yeah but
you're not you're not the partner for me
yeah you're not the man or girl I
thought you were yeah you're not the
part of clearly not gonna stand up for
me what you said why are we doing this
why did you even can't even stand up
your own mum entertained date in a
bisexual if you if when you knew this
kind of strife would happen why would
you even in state ranks and like I want
to know why my sexuality even came up in
conversation with your mum in the first
place true cuz it's not his place to say
it's not your place is not your place to
say and what what were you possibly
talking about for that to even come up
here because that's not a topic of
conversation full stop not just whole
browser girl ah she's caught she's
bisexual by the way yeah what's your new
girlfriend like yeah she's cool she's bi
she's what
she's yeah and then your mum's out there
oh you girls are the attention seeker
cuz
I would prob I lost my shoes frustration
yes there's not an [ __ ] I mean I do
agree she could she could there were
other options she could have just left
yeah
she could have even said I don't need
this and just left obviously like you
said she's probably dealt with a lot
that [ __ ] before and just just called
her a [ __ ] yeah um but the mom [ __ ]
deserves it cause anyway I don't want to
hear about outdated yeah
like this that's another thing that
annoys me is when people use their
old-school mentality as a crutch to be
rude to people regardless of what you
think yeah what you think and what you
say are two different separate entities
graphed I could be the most homophobic
Homer I'm not obviously but I could be
the most homophobic person on the planet
yeah doesn't give me the right to be
verbally abusive to someone yeah and
blah oh well the way I grew up was that
this is the case okay so why do you have
to run your mouth to someone just
because that's the way you grew up and
that's the mentality you have why do why
all of a sudden do you have to have the
right to start chucking it to people and
being abusive and root but there's never
an excuse to be rude to someone
regardless of how you were up and what
you bleep up there's no excuse to be
rude to someone yeah Brad that's wild
that's wild
he's a fuck-boy as well what's he doing
brother I thought I'd never post comment
I've had to comment on it yeah G you're
the [ __ ] 100% you the [ __ ] how
could you not think that you are is a
[ __ ] he is a [ __ ] let's wrap it up let's
see you next week guys